[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so wisconsin voted yesterday
and everything was riddled in such chaos
that and so last minute with the supreme
court deciding that indeed built the
wisconsin election was going to go on i
was planning on doing a live stream last
night with wisconsin results only to
learn like 15 minutes before the polls
closed that the bulk or really all of
the results for the presidential primary
won't be available for somewhere between
3 and 5 more days and I ended up oh I
just lost connection with Pat but I'll
keep talking here while we wait to get
him back in any case I was uh I was
planning on doing a stream and then it
turns out we're not gonna be getting
those those results let's see if we can
get Pat back here that's really weird
what happened there let's see if Pat
will call us back
very interesting we're just going to
keep going because why not
and we're Oh Pat got knocked off line it
seems very very strange what's going on
here in any case we don't know
ultimately what the results we don't yet
know what the results of Wisconsin are
ultimately going to be although it
doesn't really matter because Bernie
Sanders has indeed dropped out okay
we've got Pat backpack I just kept
talking while you were you were gone we
lost connection but in any case the
point was we're not going to know the
results Bernie has now dropped out so
it's like does it even really matter but
the hundreds of thousands of people's
lives were put at risk by having to mass
gather and vote in Wisconsin yeah I
didn't hear everything that you said
there so forgive me if I repeat some
stuff but you already had a live stream
yesterday covering Trump's press
conference and you also recorded an
entire show so I think it was okay that
you're able to skip that that other live
stream yesterday that was fine but yeah
the fact that they had voting in
Wisconsin yesterday absolutely crazy we
talked about that yesterday and just
seeing some of the images coming out of
there where they have people separated
by six feet everyone's supposed to bring
their own black or blue pens with them
so you don't have to reuse the same pens
everyone was wearing masks I mean I
guess they went about it in the best
possible way that they could but bottom
line is they shouldn't have had this
election at all well and also from some
of the video not everybody was wearing
masks but a lot of people certainly were
and the other element of confusion was
there were people who had gone through
the process of requesting absentee
ballots they never got them so then
yesterday they were put in a position to
decide do I count on getting it before
there's some number of days after during
which you're allowed to submit it they
did an extension or do you just assume
maybe I'm not getting it so I'll show up
to vote even though I did all the right
things to not have to go and show up I
mean absolute in total chaos and of
course it's easy to say if Wisconsin has
a surge in cases and deaths over the
next few days then the people who
allowed this election to go through will
have blood on their hands although you
never really can tie it back
conclusively you don't know for sure if
it was because of the election although
I think there would be strong evidence
to suggest that another interesting
tidbit and I heard this I wasn't able to
independently verify it but I did hear
that of the Supreme Court in Wisconsin
that allowed this election to go on
they didn't convene in person to make
that decision they did so remotely so
the fact that they weren't even willing
to get together with that few group of
justices to - to make sure that the
election goes through but they were
willing to have thousands and maybe
millions of residents go out there
hungry necessitating hundreds of
thousands maybe of residents go out
there to vote in a time that's just so
unsafe I mean how much does that tell
you they'll do anything to to create
voter suppression in that state and it's
just it's just despicable I'm going back
to this idea that I mentioned at this
point it's been six weeks ago which is
the virus is a crisis in and of itself
but the virus is also exposing a lot of
the weak very weak and deranged
underbelly of everything in the country
so this includes things like how fragile
the economy is you know Trump claiming
we had the best economy ever in history
up until a month ago whether you believe
that or not a lot of the numbers were
very good the fact that it instantly
crumbles shows us the systemic fragility
of the system in the same way we are
seeing the rampant corruption
sort of prioritizing politics over
everything else of so many different
bodies the to some extent even you know
some of that dr. Burks I think is half
in the tank
for Donald Trump and she can only
partially be trusted Supreme Court's
it's crazy
and we're realizing now we need backup
plans right it doesn't seem like we have
the best backup plans for this sort of
thing and looking forward to the
November 20 2011 elections across the
country it's not like the elections are
done at a national level every state
will have to decide what they're going
to do and if we have a second wave of
this thing which is certainly possible
coming in the fall and people aren't
willing and able to go out and vote at
polling places like we're used to we're
gonna have to have a system in place
whether that's mail-in voting which of
course Trump is against yeah maybe
voting online which I know that has its
own host of security issues but it seems
like going out and voting in persons
just not gonna be the best option if
we're dealing with a scenario like we
are now in November no doubt about it
and every indication so far that we will
be the question is will be will we
recognize it right away and start the
mitigation that's really the question
about what we're calling wave two news
out of Los Angeles Los Angeles Mayor
Eric Garcetti has now announced last
night that everyone should wear a face
covering when they visit essential
businesses which are the only ones that
are supposed to be open and the idea is
again the idea if you are under the
mindset that the mask is to protect
others the idea is wear a face covering
to protect the workers that are working
at the essential businesses you have to
wear a mask bandana or something else
when you go to a grocery store pharmacy
hardware store laundry restaurant which
should be just for takeout hotel taxi
uber lyft vehicle and other essential
businesses my brother lives in LA and he
had to go to the dentist yesterday now
as many of you know dentists are of the
most at risk so there's this curve right
of how closely do you work with people
there anyway then it's sort of like
ranks on a curve different professions
dentists are the most at risk because
you're literally getting right up in
someone's mouth and my brother is in the
middle of a dental treatment
where you have to go in at certain
predetermined intervals or like the
treatment doesn't work and you start to
have problems
his dentist was managing it in the
following way first of all my brother
brought you know tissues with which to
press the buttons on the elevator all
building doors are being propped open so
no one has to touch the doors of course
it's Los Angeles so it's not cold so
that's no problem when he gets off on
the dentist's floor instead of going in
through the front door they have a side
door as many dentists do which is
propped open you go directly in and
there's a sign that points you into an
actual exam room once he got in they
brought him hand sanitizer
they also had oh no I'm sorry they had
him wash his hands with the sink that's
in the room and they had him gargle with
hydrogen peroxide well and they had him
signed something that says I've not
traveled domestically for 14 days
I've not traveled internationally for 14
days I'm not experiencing any of the
following symptoms I understand that we
are in this emergency situation bla bla
bla bla bla
once they examined him they needed like
a half hour during which to like tweak
and apparatus that he needs and they
said go wait in your car for the next
half hour we'll text you when it's ready
and then you come back up so they're
taking it very seriously and the risk of
contagion with that procedure is low but
this is how serious it's gotten it
sounds like it's still possible even
with all those precautions though that's
why it's so scary yeah yeah and I think
making that the face mask mandatory for
now that makes a lot of sense especially
I think they should have gloves be
mandatory too because we do know now
that the the buyers can be airborne but
it seems like most of the transmissions
happen from people touching things and
then touching their face so I think the
gloves especially should be mandatory
when people are going to these essential
businesses and the thing that worries me
so much is like when you're checking out
at the grocery store if you're doing
like a self checkout or even if you go
to a cashier yeah and you put your
credit card in and then you you know
maybe have to put in your PIN number if
it's a debit card it's like touch the
thing a bunch of times like that's
that's what freaks me out that's why I
started wearing gloves and maybe you'll
start doing the masking too I have one
here that I can start where oh look at
that now what kind of a mask is that
that looks like a real like a good one
well it's a 3m mask but it's not
the n95 got it it's okay exactly you
know for the rest of the bonus show you
want
can you talk through it can people hear
me okay
yeah I think it's fine actually I am
comfortable with you wearing it I would
prefer you wear hey so listen I have an
admission to make and then I want to go
down to the Boris Johnson update I'm not
becoming a prepper but over the last 10
to 12 days I have been reading a lot of
articles about what you should have in
any car kit that you just leave in your
trunk what you should have in a go bag
at home and what you should have in your
home for preparedness and up until now I
really don't have that much I have a
first-aid kit I have you know a few
other items but but really not I have
like in my car I've got a paper map
atlas and one of those sort of like tin
foil type blankets I forget exactly what
it's called but it looks like tin foil
and a few other things I now and I'm
building out a list of items and once
things have settled I don't want to take
any masks away from people now or
anything but I am going to build a more
substantial supply I'm not becoming a
prepper I'm not gonna have a year worth
of food or anything like that but for me
this has really awakened not a panic in
me but just a desire to have more stuff
right so everything from waterproof
matches to a powerful lighter a lot of
backup batteries I'm probably going to
get once they are not in short supply
some n95 masks some surgical gloves I'm
gonna have a go bag I probably will get
a bunch of these bricks that you fill
with water and you can keep water you
know you have to rotate it every once in
a while but otherwise you get you just
keep water in case the water is cut off
for 72 hours I am taking it more
seriously now yeah I remember a couple
of years ago we did a segment when you
were starting to become a prepper just a
little bit you're dabbling in it and he
went over the list of items that you
bought right with this next wave of you
preparing for the next crisis was there
anything that you saw recommended for
you to purchase that you
we're surprised by that he didn't think
would help in an emergency situation but
once you saw it on the list you realize
yeah that would be useful let me let me
look I have a list that I've been
building on my in a to-do let me give
you some of the items that maybe would
be surprising to you
Soylent should probably be on there so
you can eat for a few days well I how
long does Soylent last a long time I'm
sure it has a long shelf life
maybe I'll get I mean I certainly I'm
gonna get some food supplies okay so
like here's a random item zip ties I
wouldn't ever for myself think that you
want to have zip ties but I've been
reading that there's actually they take
up so little space and are so light and
can be used for so many things you can
secure a gauze if someone has a cut with
a zip tie you can use it if you have an
electrical or a plumbing issue like zip
ties I don't know I've never would have
not a zip ties but I guess zip ties make
sense you can use them as handcuffs in
case you have to restrain someone that
is another use for them too that's a
whole other area which is self defense
items and most of the prepper websites I
don't do like the right-wing prepper
websites I do normal prepper Oh Pat
having a problem with his mouse I do I
do I do like normal prepper websites and
they try to be apolitical so they say
like you know this is a very personal
thing we're not saying you should have
guns we're not saying you shouldn't like
they because I'm not doing right-wing
prepping you know interesting I would
imagine most of the prepping is done by
right-wingers so you think they'd have
no problem including guns and all the
other stuff that you would expect from
them now I'm using the less political
prepper prepper websites okay
briefly we've heard from British Foreign
Secretary Dominic Raab that he is
confident Prime Minister Boris Johnson
will recover from the virus from the
coronavirus Boris Johnson got
coronavirus about a week ago or was
tested positive about a week ago he
became sick enough that a couple of days
ago he had to go to the hospital he then
became sick enough that he had to be
moved to the ICU he now remains in what
they call critical care I don't think
that's an ICU I believe that is a step
below the ICU based on how the UK
delineates the levels but he is not
receiving I guess he is no longer
receiving as much mechanical assistance
to the extent that he was so it seems
like he's going to be okay that's great
news
my hope with this finding is this news
surfacing I was just I was just hoping
that maybe they were doing this as a
precaution so I you know you have this
guy who's the leader of a country right
is the Prime Minister of the UK I hope
they were just trying to do it so they
could take every step possible to make
sure that he survives through this and
yeah I mean that the scary thing is like
he started getting sick like you said
about a week ago maybe a little over a
week ago I've never had an illness where
I had my symptoms persisted past like
three or four days like that's always
been the worst of it for me and so the
fact that it seems to be getting worse
for him even though he's had it for so
long that's what's so scary about this
virus very common I mean a lot of people
report you just have a somewhat of a
fever and a cough for many days and then
it gets worse and there are even reports
of it taking 60 days for full recovery
for some people most of those cases out
of China based on the timeline but it's
it's serious it's very very serious
yeah and Boris Johnson he's in his mid
50s apparently he runs every now and
then so you know he's not in the worst
shape yeah I don't think he's in that
absolute worst shape and he's maybe not
at the most at-risk category like he's
not in his 70s or 80s or whatever but
you never know with this I mean like
it's kind of rolling the dice there are
plenty of young and healthy people who
are getting really really sick and some
even dying from this virus and we don't
know exactly what causes that why it
hits some some people harder than it
does others but yeah we're all rooting
for Boris Johnson and this isn't about
politics right now we don't want anyone
to die we don't want anyone to get the
illness we're not wishing that upon
anyone of Koree and hopefully he makes
it through pretty soon I saw some data
out of New York State which of course
has a huge sample size because they have
so many cases and of all the deaths
apparently 1.2 percent of the deaths so
far have been young people without
comorbidities and I don't know whether
we should feel relieved or worried by
that number but that's the number we
have so far so far out of New York State
that actually does sound pretty low do
you know what they counted as young
people though is it like below 40 below
50 I think for the purposes of this it's
below 40 okay yeah okay that's at least
a bit of a promising sign but again it's
just weird how like there are some
people you hear about who are maybe like
20 years old and there
pleats and then they get hit with the
spires maybe it's coupled with pneumonia
and then they're fighting for their life
in a very short time and that's what has
to make you think even if you are a
young person watching this yeah you're
at risk - I mean you should do it not
only for the sake of old people but for
your own sake as well and I think no to
understanding that that will make them
act in the way that we want them to all
right that does it for today join me
later if it's later depending on when
you listen to this or today's a white
house coronavirus press briefing live on
YouTube Twitter Christian Facebook live
otherwise we will see you tomorrow the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]